chère madame erignac chers enfants de
claude erignac
c'était il ya vingt ans exactement
le soir du 6 février 1998 alors qu'il se
rendait au théâtre kallisté non loin
d'ici à pied sans protection selon son
souhait le préfet claude erignac était
lâchement assassiné de trois balles dans
la tête tirées par derrière à bout
portant
ce fut le premier préfet à tomber en
temps de paix geste sans précédent sans
équivalent ont vite alors la nation se
levait faire bloc autour de cet homme
autour de cette figure de la république
autour de sa famille le président
jacques chirac et les autorités de la
république dire aussitôt l'horreur leur
compassion absolue avec la famille leur
immense estime pour le préfet erignac et
leur détermination à ne rien céder à
ceux qui voulaient attenter à la france
et à l'état de droit
commençait alors la recherche inlassable
des coupables en vue de leur juste
punition
car ce qui s'est passé ici le 6 février
1998 ne se justifie pas ne se plaide pas
ne s'explique pas ce fut un assassinat
un attentat
rien de plus haut ni de plus noble on a
tué un homme parce qu'il était un
serviteur de la république
on a arraché un époux et un père a une
femme et a deux enfants deux infamie qui
a jamais déshonore leurs auteurs comme
l'écrivît son ami le poète jean orizet
ton assassin cher claude est bien plus
mort que toi le 11 février 1998
cinq jours après l'assassinât du préfet
partout en corse des dizaines de
milliers d'hommes et de femmes ont
exprimé leur effroi et leur indignation
lors des plus grandes manifestations que
lille ait jamais connu on compta jusqu'à
40000 personnes bravant les
intimidations surmontant la peur
qu'inspire tout barbarie ses
compatriotes se sont levés pour dire
leur colère leur dégoût
sans banderole sans discours dans le
silence d'un deuil profond
certains d'entre vous parmi les
militants de l'identité corse vous est
révolté devant le dévoiement d'une cause
déshonoré par la lâcheté le sang et la
mort la corse terre de fierté de dignité
a été sali par ce crime c'est pour cela
qu'elle s'est levée parce qu'elle ne
voulait pas qu'on la croie comptables ni
coupables de cette ignominie
parce qu'elle ne voulait pas que
certains au nom de la corse se fasse
d'une gloire de ce forfait en
l'habillant du beau nom de résistance
car on sait encore dans toutes les
familles de france et particulièrement
en corse qui fut le premier territoire
français libérée de l'occupant
ce que fut l'occupation est ce que fut
la résistance la république est sortie
victorieuse de la première guerre
mondiale et a pu renaître de la seconde
grâce à beaucoup de héros français qui
souvent furent des corses de vrais
résistants ceux qui ont refusé
l'impuissance la soumission et la
résignation
ici encore on s'est battu pour une
indépendance
c'était l'indépendance de la france et
sa place éminente parmi les nations
libres
[Applaudissements]
nous en conservons le témoignage
puissant des anciens
le nom de cette avenue nous le rappelle
qui rend hommage au colonel colonna
d'ornano avec le général leclerc il
rallia le tchad à la france libre et au
général de gaulle et il perdit la vie en
1941 en héros pour la france il fut le
premier compagnon de la libération à
titre posthume
tout près d'ici deux ans plus tard en
1943 dans la sittelle d'ajaccio le
préfet fred scamaroni lui même fils de
préfet périssé pour la liberté comme un
signe annonciateur du martyre d'un autre
grand préfet jean moulin torturé par
l'occupant fred scamaroni écrivit sur le
mur de sa cellule avec son sens je n'ai
pas parlé
vive de gaulle et vive la france
ainsi la république n'oublie ni ses
origines ni son histoire ni ses
principes ni ses combats et l'histoire
de la corse en fait partie est là c'est
mort pour la patrie et ses héros ne sont
pas des lâches
ce 6 février 1998 des français se sont
retournés contre la nation ils ont pris
les armes contre la république avec eux
derrière eux plusieurs autres ont perdu
dans cette entreprise leur honneur et
même leur âme
ce sont là des circonstances aggravantes
un tel acte n'a rien à voir avec une
prétendue lutte de libération
c'est la simple trahison des idéaux qui
nous rassemble c'est un de ces actes de
terrorisme dont notre nation eu encore
récemment à subir la barbarie
malgré cette plaie vive la république
est resté fidèle à elle-même et à sa
mission elle a protégé les corses de
cette violence je veux saluer ici la
mobilisation engagée par jean pierre
chevènement des services d' enquête qui
sous la conduite des magistrats ont
permis quelques années plus tard lorsque
nicolas sarkozy était ministre de
l'intérieur et je veux saluer ici sa
détermination extrême d'arrêter de
mettre à disposition de la justice et de
faire condamner les auteurs et complices
de cet assassinat
en inaugurant cette place claude erignac
au coeur d'ajaccio nous c'est long
mesdames et messieurs notre union
indéfectible dans la république
il aura fallu cet odieux attentat pour
que nous comprenions combien ce qui nous
unit est plus fort plus durable que ce
qui nous divise la république n'a pas
cédé elle a tenu bon face à la
provocation ultime et la corse n'a pas
sombré
elle a résisté à la spirale de violence
dans laquelle voulait l'entraîné ses
apôtres du crime et je veux vous dire
aujourd'hui ma conviction profonde c'est
que la haute figure de claude erignac a
empêché que le scandale de sa morne
entraîne à sa suite le pire car claude
erignac était cet homme de droiture
d'ouverture de rigueur et de mérite de
devoir et d'action dont la mort a
révulsé même les adversaires
il était de ces préfets qui font honneur
à la république et dont la république
sonore bien plus encore claude erignac
était préfet ce qui signifie qu'ils
étaient aux avant-postes du service de
l'état dans ses différentes fonctions
comme sous préfet puis comme préfet de
la nouvelle calédonie à la martinique de
la loire aux yvelines en passant par le
gers où la meurthe et moselle
il était animé par le souci constant du
développement des territoires et par la
passion de servir leurs habitants dans
la rigueur et la vertu des valeurs
républicaines
il était un membre éminent de ce corps
préfectoral qui assure depuis plus de
deux siècles la continuité de l'état et
l'unité de la nation
il portait dignement l'uniforme
préfectoral dont les parements orné du
chêne et de l'olivier représente la
force et la paix
je sais lui si en ce jour tous les
membres de ce corps préfectoral et tout
particulièrement celles et ceux qui ont
servi en corse qui ont servi et qui
servent la corse préfets et sous-préfets
chefs de service de l'état ici réunis
claude erignac s'était vu confier en
1996 une triple mission rétablir
l'autorité de l'état
contribuer au dialogue républicain et
faire avancer les dossiers économiques
sociaux et culturels et s'était engagé
dans la lutte contre la violence la
criminalité le terrorisme avec courage
et abnégation
il devrait d'arrache-pied à soutenir
l'économie insulaire et son agriculture
la cohésion sociale l'affirmation de
l'identité culturelle de l'île
originaire lui même d'une terre rude la
lozère où aujourd'hui il repose
il avait trouvé avec la population le
chemin d'un dialogue sans artifice il
avait gagné la confiance de tous et à
tous il donnait l'exemple d'une
république juste et attentive
son assassinat a fait de claude erignac
un de ces martyrs laïque qui tombe parce
qu'ils ont cru à leur mission parce
qu'ils ont été fidèles à leur vocation
sept morts inacceptables a résonné si
fort qu'elle a pris valeur de symbole
elle aura eu cet effet d'éloigner la
tentation de la violence et du sang elle
aura ranimer l'exigence du droit et du
dialogue démocratique cela je crois
les corses l'avait déjà compris
lorsqu'ils sont venus en nombre et en
silence rendre un hommage poignant à son
épouse et à ses enfants au moment de
leur départ de lille merci
cher claude
sheikh marie-christophine cher charles
antoine d'avoir eu le courage de revenir
ici
vingt ans après je sais combien c'était
pour vous difficile mais je sais aussi
que la république vous le devez et que
la corse l'attendait par votre courage
et votre dignité
vous avez sauvé la corse de ses démons
vous avez su alors que vous étiez si
douloureusement atteint porter votre
désir de justice avec courage dignité
retenu est imposée à tous les tenants
d'une dérive meurtrière à tous les
artisans du désordre et de la confusion
je veux ici vous saluer avec la
révérence et la reconnaissance de toute
la nation
c'est grâce à vous aussi que la justice
de la république a pu être rendue car
c'est la justice de la république qui a
été rendue et elle sera suivie sans
complaisance sans oubli sans amnistie
oh non non
au moment d'inaugurer cette place toute
l'émotion du 6 février 1998 et de ces
lendemains se réveille
nous éprouvons cette étrange amertume
qui nous rappelle de quel day se tissent
notre histoire dans ces épreuves
nous trouvons aussi la force de
consolider chaque jour notre république
madame erignac a voulu qu en ces lieux
figure ces mots ce lieu de mémoire lui
est dédié pour que jamais ne s'efface le
souvenir d'un homme qui avait choisi
librement et dignement de servir au
premier rang a découvert au milieu des
patients cette liberté cette dignité ce
courage de claude erignac ce sont les
vertus de la république elle-même
le nom de claude erignac a posé ici et 7
olivier symbole de concorde sont un
appel à la raison et le ferment d'un
dialogue renouvelé refonder assainies
c'est cela être digne de la mémoire de
claude erignac et c'est cela que tous
ici nous voulons le préfet erignac
savait qu'il venait en corse pour
dissiper un climat de confusion et
d'incertitude
vingt ans plus tard la république doit
conserver cette ambition de ménage et à
la corse un avenir qui soit à la hauteur
de ses espérances sans transiger avec
les requêtes qui la ferait sortir du
giron républicain
nous devons sans relâche pour suivre le
travail de claude erignac et uvrer à une
île réconcilier tourner vers des
lendemains meilleurs
ouverte sur le monde méditerranéen
c'est le rôle de la république
c'est le rôle
de toutes celles et ceux qui veulent
qu'ils s'y préparer l'avenir de leurs
enfants
c'est mon rôle comme chef de l'état
prenant son poste de préfet en 1996
claude erignac rédigea quelques lignes
où il résumé sa mission
les devoirs qu'elle lui imposer mais
aussi les craintes qu'elle pouvait
susciter
il redoutait en particulier ceux qu'il
appelait les faux semblants
je suis ici pour rompre avec ses faux
semblants et reprendre le chemin de la
franchise de la responsabilité et de la
construction de l'avenir sans non dits
et sans détour c'est ce que la
république doit à claude erignac pour
que son sang n'ait pas coulé en vain
c'est ce qu'elle doit à la corse sait ce
qu'elle doit à la jeunesse de corse
c'est ce qu'elle se doit à elle-même
vive la république vive la france
[Applaudissements]